Mark Steyn is the best-selling author
and really the best guest on TV and
joins us tonight so here's yet another
example mark of them accusing you of
what they're doing
are they not aware they're doing yes I
think I think Hillary Clinton is totally
unaware when she says that you know you
run the best campaign and all the rest
of it she's actually clutching at straws
as to why the inevitable candidate did
not win but but this is really the flip
side of what you were talking about with
with Molly just now because these two
stories run in parallel the Democrats
essentially provide political cover for
all these FBI types monkeying around
wiretapping and surveillance didn't lend
it political cover we would all see it
for what it is the deep snake gone rogue
at the same time the deep state's
investigation of George Papadopoulos &
Co provides cover for the Democrats as
to why Trump's victories Republican
victories are never legitimate so in a
sense these two things operate or
operate on twin tracks and support each
other but when you have someone like
Stacey Abrams actually saying we don't
need to concede any more because this
entire system is is oppressive and out
to get us
the Democrats are coming close actually
to making politics entirely impossible
and when you do that it doesn't actually
leave much else except civil war so by D
legitimizing this process they are
actually playing with matches when you
say that the election is illegitimate
because the system's illegitimate
because the founding documents are
illegitimate because the people who
wrote them were racist and at a certain
point aren't you really saying like I
don't need to play by your rules I'm
just gonna seize power when I can well
Stacey Abrams argument is unless I win
the election was rigged and Hillary
Clinton who is a far more senior figure
than Stacey a
actually came close to saying that on
stage in Los Angeles because I didn't
win the system must be rigged and
actually when he we that Nancy Pelosi
thing I don't think Trump is like that
at all I think if Trump were to lose
narrowly he'd sound off on Twitter he'd
say the presidency is for losers living
in the White House was so degrading
after you've lived in Trump Tower
I'm gonna build a fabulous new Trump
Resort in Kazakhstan
screw you all he'd have a ball with if
he lost he'd have a ball and he be gone
but what the Democrats have done for the
last two years in particular Hillary
Clinton it's it's Hillary Clinton's
refusal to lose tied to what we've been
talking about with all these deep state
guys going rogue in alliance with
foreign intelligence agencies
eavesdropping monitoring's trying to
entrap American citizens that's these
two these two crimes are actually the
the same crime and one half supports the
other half very smart as always mark
Stein thank you thanks taco great being
with you